جدل دراما اليوميه مع الناقد العزيز طارق
الشناوي
اهلا بكم استاذ طارق معنا في مسائل عربيه
اسعد مساك استاذ طارق لنبدا بالازمه
الجديده في مسلسل سر الباتع بعد ان كشف
موسيقار راجح داوود بان المخرج خالد يوسف
كان تلاعب شوي بموسيقى بمسلسل واضاف عليها
قطع موسيقيه لمؤلفين اخرين دون ان يشير
اليهم طب هذا برايك يعد مخالفه يعني خصوصا
لانه يوسف استخدم موسيقى لاعمال سابقه له
لا مؤكد مؤكد ان دي جريمه ادبيه
[موسيقى]
راجح داوود
يعني اذا كان خالد بيبيح لنفسه كمخرج انه
يستخدم زي ما هو عايز تمد سبا ان هو
يستخدمها يظل دي مسؤوليته ويتحملها لكن
لكن ما ينفعش ان حد ثاني زي موسيقاري زي
راجح داود او غيره يتحمل المسؤوليه دي لا
يعني هنا في الحقيقه جريمه لم يرتكبها
راجح وده اللي خلاه يسارع بتبرئه نفسه
امام الراي العام لان هو من اول حلقه وعلى
السوشيال ميديا في مقاطع من الريس عمر حرب
اللي عمل الموسيقى بتاعته ايضا راجح وكان
اخراج خالد يوسف
ببعض مقاطع من سر البتاع
فاتهم ان هو بيكرر نفسه فالراجل يعني
استحمل ما حبش يعني يعلن ان هو مش هو
المسؤول بعد شويه لقى ان هناك
مقاطع موسيقيه ليس له علاقه بها داخله في
العمل الفني واللي اسمه عليه يعني فمعناها
انه اللي سارق هو وضع الموسيقى وده استاذ
في الكونسل
فما ينفعش يبقى استاذ ويتهم بالسرقه فكان
هو كان غصب عنه مجبر ان هو يبرئ ساحته
امام الراي العام يقول انا غير مسؤول عن
الحدث اما كل ان خالد اتذكر بعض اعمال
سينمائيه له هو اعد موسيقها مجددا مره
اخرى منها العاصفه مثلا
اظن
قعدوا في حينه ميسره او حاجه زي كده هنا
هو المسؤول يعني عايز اقول هو العاصفه
اللي كان اللي عنده موسيقى التصويريه
استاذ كمال الطويل وكان رحل لما جاء خالد
يعمل حين ميسره لم يكن موجود فخالد يستاذن
الورثه وخدي بالك حط خط تحت تستاذن يعني
معناها انه كان لازم يبقى فيه استئذان
استاذن الورثه فانه سيعيد الموسيقى دي في
حين ميسرها وافقوا هنا بقى ما اقدرش الوم
الورثه الورثه يعني عادي انه شايفين
موسيقى كمال الطويل مطلوبه لكن المخرج
اللي بيعيد موسيقى الموسيقى الموسيقى لغه
فازاي الواحد يقدر يعيد اللغه
نروح للجزائر في جدل عاد مره اخرى حول
العنف فيها الدراما ومسلسل الدراما اللي
اعتبر منتقدون انه ايضا لا يتماشوا مع
قيموا معايير اسريه واستخدام حوار وصفوه
بانه سوقي وعنيف بالوقت اللي بقول بعض
المؤيدين انه بالعكس هو يصور جزء من
الواقع يعني هذا الجدل كله كانه في نسخه
من الاعتراض على اعمال محمد رمضان في مصر
هل اليوم يعني مطلوب من الدراما انه تكون
واعده للمجتمعات ولا كيف
هو الحق ده جدل العام جدا في عالمنا
العربي يعني بقوه في العالم موجود بشكل ما
لكن في عالمنا العربي موجود في قوه لسه
في الجزاء في السودان الشقيق الفنان صلاح
احمد حكى شيء قريب من كده فكره لما بتقدم
انت اي واقع او ما تراه واقع فيقول لك كده
انت بتروج للعنف كده بتروج ضد الاديان كده
انت متهم بانك بتخلي الناس تشرب مخدرات
يعني عايز اقول تعودنا على ان احنا نلقي
بمثل هذه الاتهامات امام الاعمال الفنيه
وانا كتبت حتى مقال بالصدفه النهارده كاتب
مقال قريب قوي من الكلام اللي قاله المخرج
انه الدراما ليست موعظه حسنه والكلام ده
هو اللي قايله يعني فوجئتي على عندكم على
على الشاشه مكتوب نفس الكلام عمره ما كانت
الدراما موعظه يعني الموعظه تبقى في
الجامع في الكنيسه لكن مش بالدرامه ولازم
نثق انه المتلقي يعني اللي يشوف رانيا
وسكينه مثلا وهو بيقتلوا مش هيطلع يقتل
الناس وسكينه يعني فكره ان احنا دايما
نقول انه الدراما ستؤدي الى جرائم ولا
قتله الى المشاغبين تبقى السبب في انهيار
منظومه التعليم مثلا يعني احنا بنزود قوي
في مهاجمه الدراما وبنراجعه الاجهزه
الرقابيه تزداد يعني دراوه في الحذف
والمنع لا يجب ان احنا نتعامل مع الفن كفن
كشاشه وانه لاصق ان المتلقي لن يصبح سفاحا
عندما يشاهد قاتل على الشاشه ولن يصبح
ايضا مدملا عندما يرى مدمن على الشاشه ولن
يصبح مغتصبا عندما يرى مغتصب على الشاشه
طب احنا ليه بنقدم كل الشخصيات دي عشان
خاطر الناس تعرف تشوف الحياه كلام جميل
دائما يا استاذ طارق وهيدي هذا الكلام
بنخليه بمقاله هلا كمان قريبا اليوم
اشكرك جزيل الشكر القاهره ناقد الفني
الشناوي